so thanks for sticking around to the end
of the day must be tired by now how many
users of Kafka do we have in here okay a
lot okay that's gonna make this much
easier so I'm going to tell you about
exactly one semantics in Kafka this is a
new feature that we've added in 0.11
which was released only a couple months
ago so like what does it actually mean
and how to use it so let's Oh Who am I
I'm Jason I'm an engineer at confluent
I'm also an Apache Kafka committer we
were the team responsible for bringing
exactly one semantics but we weren't the
team that actually originated the idea
so this has been in the works for a long
time goes back to LinkedIn days for
example when Kafka was run at LinkedIn
um
that's so brief overview of the talk I'm
gonna just give an overview of Kafka
just at the level that we need to
understand in order to talk about
exactly one semantics so I'm gonna cover
very high level high level overview then
we're going to talk about the old
semantics and a little bit of detail
just so we can understand where exactly
they break down and then we'll discuss
exactly one semantics in some depth and
finally we have if there's enough time
we'll go on to observations in some
areas for future improvements very
briefly since we have a lot of coffee
users here I'm not going to dwell on
this and Kafka is like a central nervous
system for where your data where your
data is passing so we like to say all
streams lead to Kafka it's it's sort of
as true as soon as Kafka's in your
architecture then all data goes through
it so you publish data to its you
subscribe data from it and you process
data on top of Kafka Kafka organizes
data into topics topics are organized
into partitions so partition is kind of
like the the unit of state that you know
we're able to move around the cluster
each yeah and the fundamental data
structure of a partition is this this
log of messages as which is
we have this sequential offset as
messages are added to it they get
assigned an increasing offset and very
briefly you know we're gonna spend a lot
of time in this talk looking at the log
because it's really the best way to
understand what is happening inside of
Kafka a blog message itself consists of
you know offset key value timestamp and
headers that's a new feature for the
most part we're not concerned with most
of those fields where we'll focus on the
offset and maybe mentioned other fields
when we need them but for a large part
what will will kind of go with this
simpler representation of log so as i'm
as i mentioned before partitions as are
the the unit of of state so partitions
are replicated among the brokers you can
have as many replicas as you want you
know typically three or four and then
one of those replicas is basically
assigned as the leader and so this is
kind of this is how we get our
durability and available availability so
the leader fails one of the replicas is
promoted so Kafka clients there are two
kinds producers right two partitions
consumers read from partitions or topics
if you want to look at it that way let's
just understand very quickly how the
producer works so producers as I said
they're always writing to the leader the
leader is replicating to the follower
and you know you're the creatures
typically writing to multiple partitions
this replicated replication is happening
all the time
you have many producers writing to the
logs all at the same time and you just
kind of proceed this way so in the case
of a failure you know we have the one of
the other replicas becomes the leader
and all requests are routed to it and
once the the old broker comes back
online it comes back online as a
follower it catches up and then you know
in order to try to keep the balance on
the overall cluster it would become the
leader again and and then we resume so
there are a couple from a protocol
perspective
okay in Kafka protocol is very simple
it's a request response protocol there's
one point about the produce protocol in
particular that I want to mention
because it pertains to semantics so we
have just a very simple produce request
which is received by the broker we write
to the log and depending on the the
semantics that you want from the
producer you know replication may happen
before we return but any case we write
to log and then you will get some kind
of acknowledgement it can happen that
you fail to get that acknowledgement in
which case typically the producer is
going to retry and retrying and we'll
talk about this more in depth but you
can see there's kind of a protocol
limitation it results in in duplicates
in the log okay so Kafka consumer so
consumers read sequentially from the law
from the partitions and you know it kind
of works like this or they're reading
sequentially once you hit some kind of a
stable point you write your position to
another topic as you know consumer
offsets topic and if you fail this is
where you're going to look for your your
beginning position and typically then
the nice thing about Kafka and the
reason why I probably why it's so
successful is you can have many
consumers all consuming from different
points in the log all at their own pace
and all you know committing their own
offsets and why not the protocol just
want to mention just want to mention
this really quickly there's two api's
that the consumer uses from a basic
level that's offset fetch this is where
where I look up what the current the
last committed offset is and so it's
typically looks like this I look up
what's what was the last committed
offset it's X then I start fetching from
X and you know I get data back process
it and then the the offset commit is
where I write that to the log so the
main point is really just that there's
there's a separate API for writing to
the log for this offset commit
so in order to talk about semantics we
need some kind of a model this is gonna
be pretty informal but basically the
model we have in mind is this read
process right we have input topics where
we're reading from and output topics
where we're writing to and some kind of
processor which is transforming the
input in into the outputs we are
interested in a couple different kinds
of failures so our semantics should
protect us in spite of these kind of
failures so crashes you process crashes
we should be able to recover and ours
you know delivery semantics should be
preserved and similarly zombie so in
some cases you know like a a long GC or
something like this when if a process
comes back to life even though we
thought it were dead our semantics
should still protect us so let's talk
briefly about you know the semantics
that are possible it's not comprehensive
but this is sort of a typical few at
least once this is the default in Kafka
and it's what was only possible or the
limits of what was possible in Kafka
prior to 0.11 and it basically means
that all input is processed and the
result is reflected at least once in the
output so it means there could be
duplicates at most once yeah it's kind
of weird but it means you're you can
accept some message loss but you just
don't want to duplicate it's mostly
useful to talk about for pedagogical
purposes then exactly once this is kind
of what you really want you know if you
if you've got a processor which is just
copying the input to the output and you
you got end messages on the input you
want end messages on the outputs and you
want them in the same order there's you
know some theoretical work to generals
problems and whatnot we're not
disproving any of that I think as this
talk goes on it will become clear what
the what is actually possible and what
the limitations are there's one
assumption though that I just want to
mention so we do assume that you know as
far as topic availability is concerned
so topics may be unavailable for some
amount of time but we assume in the long
term they
you know eventually they're going to
become available so let's go into this
at least once semantics a little bit
this is some pseudocode which should
give you an idea of how the consumer and
the producer will work together so we've
got this is this is not an actual code
it's just pseudocode but let's just walk
through it really quick so we have a
subscribe API which is where the you
express interest in the topics that you
want to consume you pull two poles where
you get the actual data that's where the
fetching is happening from the current
offset the consumer is maintaining your
position in the log for you you do some
processing of some kinds it's just kind
of what really what Kafka streams is
doing then you send that output you know
using this API and finally went once you
do that to you commit offsets this it's
not really much of an exaggeration to
say that I've spent most of the last two
years thinking about what happens in
Sindh and in pole so for this talk we I
want to condense this a little bit so
we're going to go through a few examples
where we discuss exactly where in at
least one semantics duplicates can
emerge and for this you know the
processing is not too interesting so
we're just going to copy input two
outputs so we have this very simple loop
right here so the input in this case is
just a sequence of increasing numbers
which we're going to copy to the output
for simplicity we're just going to copy
one message at a time so yeah what this
looks like we when we when we start
we're pulling for data send it to the
outputs commit our offsets and then we
continue so what can happen we mentioned
that the proto the producer protocol is
not safe you know because of this issue
with retries so what can happen is you
lose that acknowledgement you retry okay
now I've got a duplicate in the log okay
and we commit offsets like normal the
second problem that can happen is you
send successfully to the top
like and then you have a crash so in
this case when you resume you're going
to pull from the latest committed offset
which in this case is two which means
the next message we need to consume is
two and we're going to have another
duplicate okay and then finally there's
one more this is a little bit more
subtle but you know we may have fetched
some data and then suddenly you know we
have some kind of system event that
causes us to hang and it hangs for a
while eventually we decide that you know
we need to start up another another
process to continue the same work so we
do so and we continue like we did before
you know and then suddenly our old
process wakes back up and sends data to
the log ok so there's another source of
duplicates so just briefly summary do
please do placate scum from producer
retries failure before committing
offsets and zombies so I most want
semantics I just want to cover this
quickly all you really do in Kafka if
you want at most once a minute six just
change the order of those two operations
so what it kind of looks like is this
you commit your offset first then you
send the data you commit your offsets so
we mentioned that's you know producer
retries are not safe you can have
duplicates that way so if you really
want at most one semantics you can't
retry so in this case if you lose lose
the acknowledgments oh well you just go
on the other thing that can happen so
you can make your offsets and then
suddenly we crash or you restart well we
lost that message okay and then finally
the last thing yeah we can't we can have
another zombie case so we're just about
to write data to the log we could become
a zombie then we start a new process
across
let's let's save the question for the
end please okay so in this case we
continue processing some data oops sorry
about that when the zombie wakes it can
send that data so yeah your question is
about yeah where specifically did you
become a zombie so it can happen it can
happen basically anywhere so it could be
internal into the producer for example
we had already processed the data go
into the producer it experiences some
kind of GC event or something like this
and then and then finally when it wakes
up it sends that data okay so in summary
it's kind of similar to at least once
retries are not safe failure before
writing the data and zombies can cause
kind of strangeness so semantic
weaknesses if we want to summarize them
so producer retries don't save the
process data is not written atomically
with the corresponding offsets so this
is the weakness in both of those those
cases you guys are you guys hearing that
you know what the cost of that is
okay let's try again okay okay and then
finally the last issue is that we don't
have protection from zombies okay so
let's deal with the first one the first
problem so this is actually the easiest
one to address what we do is we
introduce what we call the item potent
producer we introduce basically it's a
sequence number so we identify producer
instance by producer ID and then we have
a sequence number which is used to
deduplicate so into the producer if you
want to enable this you just turn on
this flag enabled idempotence equals
true so how does this work
we'll go through an example just very
quickly so your producing data with a
sequence number you know particular
producer ID and a sequence number gets
written to the log as long as you writes
with the next expected sequence number
it will be accepted now if we happen to
lose the ACK we retry and now we can
detect a duplicate okay so now we made
producer retries safe the next the next
problem takes a little bit more work to
solve how do we make the writing of
offsets and the data automic so for this
we we look at this so the motivation for
this comes from a little bit of a
different problem which is computing a
consistent snapshot in a distributed
system so we have this this chandi
Lamport paper and this is going to be an
oversimplification of that paper but it
should convey the basic idea so we've
talked a lot about this processor of
course you know we're processing this
data intending for it to get consumed by
someone so we have an observer from the
channel and poor perspective okay what
we want to do is think about these
output topics as basically a channel
that the processor is being is using to
communicate with the observer and the
question that the observer is asking how
can I see a consistent state of
processing so the processing is going
along we're computing state internally
and we're writing asynchronously to all
of these to the output partitions and
the observer is reading asynchronously
so it wants to know when it's hit some
kind of a stable point where it can you
know report data to the user for example
so the way this works is the processor
is writing data to the log and then when
it's ready when it's reached some kind
of consistent point it writes these
marker messages to the log so like the
snapshot marker it writes it out on all
partitions as soon as the observer sees
it on on one of those partitions then it
can stop you basically mute that
partition and then wait for it to come
on all all of the partitions and once it
gets all the snapshot markers it knows
it's reached a consistent point and
similarly yeah you continue on to the
next phase of computation and you
continue right our markers just like
that okay so the questions that we have
about this are how do we handle
different kinds of failures so soft
failures some some aired during
processing or hard failures like an
actual crash you know naively if you can
if you can imagine the processor it
picks up from the last snapshot and then
maybe resumes work if it just tries to
start writing to the log well you know
we never actually cleared out that old
state so the observer doesn't know that
the processor crashed so it would maybe
see an inconsistent States so another
idea in order to solve this when we
restart we want to send kind of a new
marker which tells the observer that
we're we're resetting state and you
should go back to the last snapshot so
we have this reset marker instead which
we said as soon as the observer sees it
it's going to reset to the last snapshot
and we can continue okay so this is
really what Kafka transactions are about
instead of a snapshot a reset marker we
call it committable
and yeah a few if you encounter some
kind of soft failure you can write those
abort markers so let's just take a very
quick look at what this looks like it's
not really that different we're
processing data as soon as we're ready
to commit we start writing markers
commit commit if we have any kind of
error during processing we can abort it
there is still one issue though which is
if we start the process of writing these
markers what happens when we crash so if
we kind of naively when we start up
maybe we try to abort what's ongoing
well it doesn't really work because
we've already committed that data on
that partition okay so what we do to
solve this problem is we introduce a
two-phase commit with a transaction log
so the way this works you write your
intent to commit or abort to the log
then you write all your markers and then
you write some kind of a completion of
that commit or abort to the log ok so
now we can try this again before we
write any data to the partitions we send
a message to the log saying that's where
we have a transaction it's ongoing and
it's including these three partitions we
write the data as soon as we're ready to
commit we write that that marker know
after that marker is sorry that prepare
commit to the transaction log after that
is there then it means basically that
we're we're doomed to commit eventually
so at that point it's safe to continue
or to start writing the markers once
we've finished writing the markers we
can complete the commit and we can start
a new transaction we don't necessarily
have to always include the same
partitions in this case maybe we just
include the first two we'd go through a
similar process maybe we hit some kind
of a error during processing then we
prepare abort now we go to write our
markers and then maybe we suddenly have
a crash
so in this case we'll restart the
process and the first thing we'll do is
we'll look inside this transaction log
to see what were we doing before we were
preparing to abort so that means we need
to write markers and it's okay if we
write the same marker twice there's no
data in between it so what does this
give you basically it gives you atomic
rights across multiple partitions and
that includes consumer offsets so
consumer offsets are really just another
topic so we can include them like in a
transaction just like any other topic oh
sorry
and that's really what we needed in
order to solve this other weakness so
the next one is protection from zombies
[Music]
yet if you want to stop a zombie you
need a fence but first we need to have a
way to identify a producer instance
across restarts for that we introduced
this ID called the transactional ID and
this is specified by the user so there's
there's kind of two different options
you can either have the ID generated by
the broker or by the server or you can
have it generated by the user so if you
generate it by you know within the
library or by the server then the user
is going to have to take on the burden
of persisting that somewhere so that it
can be reused when it's when when the
processor starts back up so we opted for
the alternative which was the user needs
to tell us you know which which instance
you are a producer is so I want to take
just a very brief detour from the zombie
fencing problem just because it's
difficult to find a place to put this in
the presentation and discuss transaction
log availability so this this pertains
to this transactional ID so the
transaction log
is also just a topic in Kafka and that
means it has multiple partitions each of
those partitions is replicated so the
transaction log
we each transactional ID is mapped to
one of the partitions of that
transaction log topic so we have for
this we have this fine coordinator
request so whoever the the leader of
that partition that that transactional
ID is mapped to whoever that leader is
we call its transaction coordinator so
this fine coordinator request is used to
find it so in this case we're mapping to
transaction the partition 0 so the
coordinator should be 1 and from that
point on you know we store that State
locally and all of our transactional
requests are going to go to broker 1 so
nice thing about this is you know you
have many different transactional IDs
out there they're all mapping to
different partitions so the transaction
coordinator does not become a bottleneck
you can have as many coordinators as you
want because you can have as many
partitions as you want so if there's
some kind of yeah but let's focus in on
this partition 0 for a second of course
in general it's going to be replicated
to other brokers now if there's some
kind of a failure here you know what
we're going to have regular leader
election take place the producer is
going to notice that the coordinators
down maybe because it got a disconnect
or something like this
find coordinator again we find the new
coordinator and now we can continue
okay so I've just brought this up here
because we were talking about
transactional ID now let's go back to
Zombie fencing so in order to the actual
offense itself like in many distributed
systems it's an epoch so the epoch is
tied to a producer ID the epoch
increments when the producer is
initialized so the epoch is used on the
broker to tell who is who is the latest
the latest producer if we get an epoch
from a producer which is small
than what is known to be a current epoch
then we can we can reject it so this is
added to both the transaction log
message and the data log message because
they both need fencing so let's just go
through an example of how this works for
the two in order to get the producer ID
in order to get the epoch we have this
in a producer API start maybe we write
it to the log as soon as we've done that
the producer gets its epoch it's gonna
store it locally and then you know maybe
it can start doing a transaction so in
this case we will start a transaction it
has just a single partition and for that
like we went through that example before
we write message to the log saying that
the transaction is ongoing and then yeah
if we consider the data partition that's
included in that transaction this
producer is now safe to start writing to
it
so if then maybe this producer one turns
into a zombie and we start up another
instance and just like before you know
because it shares the same transactional
ID it's going to get mapped to the same
coordinator and it's going to also call
this in a producer ID and this is where
we do where we bump up the epoch and we
immediately we begin to abort so there
was an ongoing transaction and we start
the abort process so while this is going
on before we've written any markers or
anything like this it's still possible
for the old producer to continue writing
to the data topic because that's the you
know the epoch there is is still the
highest one that the broker has seen but
as soon as that marker gets in there
with the incremented epoch then that
producer can be fenced and alternatively
you know after after the inner producer
ID call had returned and we got the new
EPIK so another case the producer you
know maybe it wasn't writing to the data
topic anymore it was getting ready to
commit to the commit the transaction you
know in that case obviously we have the
higher epic inside the transaction log
so it's fenced so that solves us from
the zombies so let's take a look at the
API very quickly again this is
pseudocode we have this new init
transactions so this is really where the
fencing is taking place we have a begin
transaction this is kind of obvious and
we have this new API here so before we
were committing offsets through the
consumer but now we need to include
those offsets as part of the transaction
so we added this API to the producer to
send offsets and what you notice also is
that's the sent offsets also this
commits they throw producer fenced
exception so if we do get fenced maybe
be good because we became a zombie we're
asleep for a while then we expect to get
raised the producer fenced exception if
you receive that then basically the only
thing you can do is close the producer
you would you can't really continue so
again we're gonna we're going to
simplify this a little bit just copying
input to output so let's go through this
example pretty quickly now we're now
we're to making it transactional so
we're sending the data send the offsets
and when we commit we write our markers
okay continue along like this it could
be the case that you know we crash we'd
only written one marker that's fine when
we restart we'll go through this in two
transactions the last thing in the log
is this prepare commit so we'll complete
it and then we'll continue yeah another
case that can happen maybe we crash just
after we had sent the data when we wake
up in it transactions again this
protects us so we abort this transaction
and we continue okay so I think one more
case maybe that's interesting okay so
let's just yeah I think you'd probably
believe me by now but that zombie case
is covered if we had become a zombie
after writing the data and writing the
offsets so again we start up a new
process our init transactions is going
to fence off both of these topics and
it's going to abort the transaction so
then we're going to continue okay now if
we try to commit the transaction nothing
happens because we're fenced
okay so we've mostly discussed this
processor here let's stop there and
let's look at the observer for a minute
observer of course in Kafka is just just
a consumer I want to discuss what
transactions mean for a consumer in the
consumer configuration we have this
isolation level which you can configure
so read committed only committed
messages are readable read uncommitted
everything is readable now the consumer
read isolation is a little bit subtle
the first issue that I want to mention
is you know typically the the transact
the partitions that are included in the
transaction are sitting on different
brokers and when you have a part
transaction which covers that there's no
synchronization between the two brokers
when you start the roll forward process
when you start to write the markers so
as soon as we get the marker on one
partition that data is visible so the
consumer can read that data even though
the other partition has not got the
marker yet okay so the point is that's
yeah there's no read atomicity across
partitions as far as transactions are
concerned okay the other issue that I
want to discuss
so it takes a little bit of background
to understand
so Brooker fetch handling Kafka's fetch
handling is is very performant and the
reason is because it's very very simple
sorry about that
well we do you know this this is this is
basically all Kafka does internally so
we get a fetch for an offset at a
particular offset and the consumer tells
us how many bytes of data that it wants
so we look up that offset and we find a
physical file position from the log so
we have kind of this this sparse index
and basically we just do a binary search
on it and then we have the file position
and all we do is we use send file to
copy the data directly to the output so
we we look good we just copy M bytes of
data so we don't do any processing like
we don't bring that data into memory we
just copy it directly from the log so we
take that this goes back to kind of you
know the very early days of Kafka one of
J's very early papers meant you know
this is part one of the key design
principles I guess of Kafka so we take
quite a bit of pain to preserve this
so-called zero copy optimization now
when the log contains transactional data
what does that mean well in order to
avoid having to you know do any kind of
filtering on the this data which would
require us to take it into memory and
lose that zero copy what it means is
that we we don't we don't filter the
aborted transactions so they actually
get returned to the client and the
client is the one that's responsible for
filtering so from the clients
perspective what does that mean
there's a potential issue here which is
you know you send an offsets let's say a
fetch request at offset zero say you get
back you see two transactions but you
don't really know
but you don't really know what the
result of those transactions is so you
keep on fetching and finally maybe you
see that one of them is committed so
then maybe you can return that data and
then maybe you find eventually that the
other one is returned as well the issue
is that until you see those markers you
know what are you what are you doing
with that data because you can't return
it to the user in until you know it's
committed so do you have to buffer it
well that would be less than ideal so in
fact what we do is a little bit what we
do is a little bit different we give the
consumer a hint when the in the fetch
response we return the data as just a
big chunk of bytes and we also return a
hint as to where where those aborted
transactions actually begin so we
include in particular the the starting
offset of the aborted transactions and
the consequence of that is yeah since we
have to we need to be able to return
this reliably to the user we say that's
messages are not readable at all until
they have been committed or aborted so
how does this actually look how does
this change this picture well when we
send a fetch at offset zero we get back
that's yeah we get back the same data
plus this aborted transaction that which
begins at offset two so immediately we
can return that data even though we
haven't seen any markers so this just
continues along like this eventually we
see those markers and we can continue so
there is kind of a subtle point here
though which I want to mention now in
the face of concurrent transactions the
question is you know here we have a
committed transaction and one which has
not been committed yet or committed or
aborted so the question is when can we
return the data from that first
transaction you know are we are we
to wait for the other transaction to
complete first so that we can return the
whole transaction or can we return only
a part of it so you know in kind of a
simple case we might immediately see the
abort marker come next for the other
transaction and it's clearly safe to
return all of this data but in another
case it could be that we have another
transaction begin before we see that
abort marker so sort of by induction we
could end up prolonging this process of
not being able to return the data
because we're trying to return it in
whole okay so what we do in is we
basically we weaken the read semantics a
little bit and we say that okay where we
can return part of that transaction but
we don't return any data pass to this
undecided point okay so what we call the
last stable offset this is the offset
such that all all prior messages at
earlier offsets have been committed or
aborted and everything up to that point
is fecha ball now as we continue as we
see other transactions as they become
committed or aborted we're able to move
that last stable offset forward and see
more more of the data okay the key point
there is again about to read atomicity
so there there's no read atomicity as
far as a transaction is concerned so
let's just summarize very quickly what
Kafka exactly wants semantics means
idempotent producer exactly once in
order transactional producer atomic
rights across multiple partitions and
the read committed consumer well what
we're limited to saying is you know you
only return committed messages
so we're getting close on time I just
want to mention a couple performance
observations so if you think about the
now that you understand what a
transaction is you know all of the
overhead comes at the beginning of the
transaction and
end of the transaction when you're in
the middle of it you know all you're
doing is producing using you know normal
rights to topics so you can sort of make
the overhead of a transaction are you
know proportionally as as small as you
want by increasing the size of that
transaction but the the problem is that
it will also increase the latency
because we do not return the undecided
data to the uncommitted data to the
consumer so you have this this this
trade-off that you need to think about
now I'm gonna skip through this a little
bit yeah I limited the processing model
quite kind of intentionally so kafka iOS
is really covering processing you know
within within Kafka so if you've got
yeah we were we were looking at this
process model before I just made a
little bit more concise as long as
you're staying in Kafka exactly once
semantics are protecting you and you
know Kafka streams gives you this you
just enable this property processing
guarantee equals exactly once and you're
done but eventually you want to get that
data out of Kafka maybe to put it
somewhere else in a date in
elasticsearch or something like this and
for that you need some kind of
coordination with that remote system
cough-cough connect already has a number
of implementations of you know cough
sinks which provide this for HDFS
elasticsearch and so on then the other
side of this you know your data doesn't
originate inside Kafka unfortunately it
has to come from somewhere and you have
Kafka connects sources which potentially
can do this this is still a work in
progress and in general you still need
the coordination of the of the source
system you know if you have a model
which is sort of like Kafka where you
where you have a partition which you can
track with kind of an increasing offset
you could do the same thing using Kafka
you know Kafka transaction that we do
with with Kafka itself but that's still
work-in-progress future improvements
yeah we want to do something about this
latency I think this is the biggest
issue
in kafka streams I'm not gonna discuss
this at depth but speculative execution
this is kind of decide to you so you say
that aborted transactions these are
probably rare in practice so what you do
is you you read in uncommitted mode and
as you're reading you assume that's the
trend the transaction will eventually be
committed and then if you later find out
oh it's it was aborted well then you do
some rolling back okay so that that's
the basic idea that we're looking at
okay so we're at the end thanks for
bearing with me this this wasn't all my
work a big team did this and you know
the work goes back to a lot of coming
contributions from community members as
well if you want to read more about it
Kip 98 says Kafka improvement proposal
we have a large large design document
which you can read as well if you're
really interested Apache Kafka if you
are yeah it they sort of basically the
links if you were if you want to learn
more about it or if you're interested in
participating like contributing or
anything like this we're always welcome
to have more contributors ask questions
if you're if you're having problems let
us know and then yeah finally
confluence obligatory we're hiring so
thank you all and off I'll stick around
for a while
[Applause]